It's been
23 days
since a train carrying
hazardous materials
went off the rails
in East Palestine, Ohio.
23 days of dread
for the nearly 5000 Americans now asking
whether their air is safe to breathe
and their water is safe to drink.
And like so much else in America,
this environmental disaster
quickly divided the country
along partizan lines.
Former President Trump led
that charge when he visited the town
inside a deep
red pocket of Ohio on Wednesday.
Unfortunately, as you know,
in too many cases, your goodness
and perseverance,
you are met with indifference
and betrayal.
In some cases,
they were doing nothing for you.
They were intending to do
absolutely nothing for you.
Transportation Secretary Pete Buda, judge
who visited the town
a day after Trump's trip,
flatly dismissed that accusation.
What we've seen
is industry goes to Washington
and they get their way.
They got their way on a Christmas tree
of regulatory changes
that the last administration
made on his way out the door
in December of 20, 20
but caught in the middle of all of this
are the residents of East
Palestine who just want to know
if it's safe to resume their lives.
Just listen to one resident confront
the CEO of the rail
company at a CNN town hall last week.
And feel safe in this town now.
You took it away from me.
Did you shorten my life?
Now I want to retire and enjoy it.
How are we going to enjoy it?
Do I mow the grass Do I
can I plant tomatoes next summer?
What can I do?
Every day
I cough through a little cough here.
A little cough.
I've never had it
I got rashes on my cheek
and all my arm from the firm to do.
I don't call it a rail
and I call it a disaster.
Let's discuss all of this
and more with CNN's Jeff Zeleny,
CNN's Melanie Sloan,
Politico's Heidi
Przybyla, and The Atlantic's Adam Harris.
This is become a much bigger situation,
I think, than
the White House anticipated.
They would
they would concede that,
but they didn't really see the politics
of this coming.
But I want to start, though,
just from a real perspective.
We just heard from that man.
The people of East Palestine are asking
for really practical things.
They're asking for water.
They're asking for help.
And if the question is,
is that being provided
from the federal government,
here is the answer
that the Ohio governor has given,
who is a Republican Mike DeWine.
He said, yes, the president called him.
He said, we don't need anything.
Here's his spokesperson
telling The Washington Post
that the agencies
provide the appropriate response
and was the president of the White House
in touch with the governor frequently?
The answer to those questions are yes.
He also described the EPA,
the EPA, as extremely responsive
So on some level,
there's the practical
and there's a political
from the practical perspective,
the Republicans in the state say
the federal government is responding
But on the political,
we're hearing something else.
Without question.
You know,
and the White House,
if you talk to officials,
they will concede that they were slow
to recognize the optics
of the seriousness of this.
They did send the EPA.
And the president
does not go to every disaster site.
It's not of course it's not possible.
The vice president
doesn't go to every disaster site.
There weren't any fatalities in this.
So they were
sort of sending
the appropriate officials
as they saw them.
There's about a thousand
a train derailments
every year in the country.
This is different on many levels
because of the optics of it.
Yes, there are serious
questions and ramifications
about the soil, about water.
But really, this became
seized upon by
the right
wing media
in many respects and fanned the flames.
And the Biden administration
allowed them to do that
because they did not optics Leigh Show.
And it was all happening at the same time
the president was in Ukraine.
So just this confluence of events
it made, it is Palestine
versus Ukraine
and it really just shined a light
on the divide in the country.
And of course, this county, Columbiana
County.
72% voted for Trump and 27%.
And we had we have those numbers.
And it's an interesting
the political dynamics here.
I mean, look at this county.
2000. It went for Bush by three.
By 20, 20.
It was up Trump by 40. Five.
So this is absolutely Trump country.
It makes sense that he would be there
and that he would be pressing the
peace process.
And it also coincides with him
launching his campaign
and I might also note
that this is
one of those places in the country
that you would consider a news desert.
So a lot of these people
who are his supporters don't realize
that a lot of the policies
that the Trump administration
stood for are policies that might
or stood against,
might, might have helped in this case,
including gutting the EPA.
The EPA were the first ones out there
monitoring the water,
monitoring the toxic fumes,
the train regulations that were gutted
under Trump Again,
these are all things
that you question yourself.
Would these things have helped?
And then thirdly,
the tax cuts,
the corporate tax cuts
that a lot of these companies
took advantage
of were not required
to be reinvested into things
like safety regulations.
But these are not things
that his voters are going to know.
So they're very impressionable.
This is a very emotional issue.
We're not going to know
for possibly decades
the full ramifications
of the health impact
on a lot of these resources.
And interestingly,
the governor, Mike DeWine,
is saying to Congress,
this train wasn't marked
as carrying
extremely hazardous materials,
and so it wasn't
subject to a lot of regulations.
Why is that?
Is Congress going to fix that?
But I want to play here.
This is what President Biden said
to reporters on Friday
about whether he would go
to East Palestine
where he planning to travel to.
He called this problem not.
I've spoken with every single major
figure in both the United Way
and both Pennsylvania and Ohio.
And so the idea that we're not engaged
is is simply not not there.
What do you make of that? Adam?
Should he go?
You know, as Jeff said, right.
This this
president's don't travel
to every disaster, anything.
The optics of this. Right.
He's travel to Ukraine at this point.
It is probably politically smart
for him to travel
to Palestine, Ohio,
in order to to sort of,
you know, remind people
that, yes, it's not just my agencies
that are here,
but it is also to me
that that is here for you as well.
But as you were as you were saying,
this was a county
that the president, the former president
carried by a significant margin. Right.
If there's one thing that we know
about the former president,
he enjoys shoring up his base.
He likes to talk to his people.
And so it's not a surprise
that he went out there.
And it's also not a surprise
that Republicans have seized on something
where they've talked for years
about this
being a place
that America's forgotten about.
The Democrats have forgotten about
that when the president doesn't visit
a place like East Palestine,
it becomes a significant issue.
Yeah.
And I think at this point,
Jeff, you made this point,
the White House
didn't anticipate
that this would become
a political punching bag.
And for that, they actually are at fault.
I mean, they're
supposed to be paying attention to this.
But here's the Pete footage of it all.
He has been at the center of this,
even though the cleanup
is the responsibility
of a different agency, the EPA.
Listen to
how Fox anchors have been talking
about him this week.
If Pothole Pete seems
lazy and out of touch
to all of you, that is because it's true.
The guy didn't
put his arm around a single person
and tell him
everything is going to be all right.
And this is the guy Democrats
think can be president.
The man should never have been
put in this position in the first place
and should be fired immediately.
There's never been a Cabinet secretary,
this flamboyantly incompetent
and this so obviously uncaring
almost to the point of evil.
If we're being honest about it,
I mean,
we are.
What's interesting to me
is that
this is the transportation secretary,
but they're the ones
bringing up running for president,
it seems.
This is a
proactive step to keep the judge down
or not.
It's pretty clear to me
that they do see him
as a potential rival here
for president
at some point in the future.
Maybe not in 24,
but maybe four years
down the line from then.
But he is in the crosshairs, right?
I mean, I think it was an unforced error
to not have them.
And he acknowledged
he admitted that
I mean, obviously,
there's the tangible things
that the government has provided,
but there's also the lack of trust
in the community.
And seeing the government officials
showing up,
I think was an important step
that even the transition
secretary admitted.
That being said,
I mean, he he has this platform.
It can be a powerful platform
to raise his profile.
We saw him,
you know, sticking it to the airlines.
He was also
at the center
of the freight rail negotiations.
And he's also been
taking a lot of heat
for these things as well.
So there's the potential for blowback.
And you see Republicans seizing on that.